well Rob is still at the Ahmed binali
stadium in Al Orion and Rob Gareth
Southgate was under a lot of pressure
before the maps to shuffle his pack he
did and it came up drums didn't it
yeah absolutely he dispelled the
doubters once again Gara Southgate
particularly by responding to those
calls for Phil foden to come into the
team as well as Marcus rashford and what
an impact they made not so in the first
half something that Gareth Southgate was
a bit disappointed by but they really
came to life in the second half once
foden and rashford switched wings and
then they made that telling impact and
it really shows the depth of quality
available to Gareth Southgate why so
many think actually this is an England
side that should be going foreign at all
and even further than the semi-finals in
2018 with a chance to reach the final
and now they do have four days rest
which will be so important particularly
given they've come straight from a
Premier League season a chance to
recover before facing Senegal the
African Champions who will be a far
tougher proposition than Wales presented
and for Wales what a disappointing
tournaments it turned out to be they've
obviously taken 64 years to return but
their Stars couldn't shine particularly
tonight Gareth Bale forced off with a
hamstring injury at half time he just
wasn't able to make an impact and for
Wales they just struggled to challenge
England at all and for England it's
their flag on the stadium behind me lit
ups and George there they crossed that
lit up across the stadium England fans
celebrating and able to extend their
stay in Qatar right the way through into
December